bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir comment rebâtir la confiance
bonsoir Patrick aubertelli merci d'être
notre grand témoin ce soir la confiance
nouvel horizon social point
d'interrogation c'est l'ouvrage que vous
avez codirigé aux éditions du champ
social vous enseignez à Centrale Paris
et avec des experts de terrain d'horizon
très divers vous interrogez la crise de
confiance dans nos institution dans nos
élus dans l'école dans les médias dans
les syndicats le lien se délite c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire alors comment
rebattir le contrat social dans un monde
incertain chaotique même anxiogène vous
nous le direz tout à l'heure il y a pas
mal de réponses à donner tout à l'heure
dans la deuxième partie notre grand
débat ce soir une ministre en surc dans
la tourmente Amélie ouea casterra cible
de toutes les critiques cell des
enseignants une nouvelle fois dans la
rue aujourd'hui et celle des députés sur
qu'il auditionnait sans ménagement vous
allez le voir à l'Assemblée nationale
choc des savoirs groupe de niveau peut-ê
encore défendre sa feuille de route nous
en débattons dans un instant sur ce
plateau enfin nos affranchis ce soir
l'économie Fanny guinochet la société
Cécilia gabizon et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le sommaire on y
va Patrick auertelli ça vous regarde
c'est
parti
[Musique]
l'exaspération joue forcément depuis la
polémique sur la scolarisation de son
fils dans le privé Amélie oua Castera
cristallise la colère des enseignant
après une première journée d'action le
1er février il défilait une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui pour défendre l'école
publique et alerté sur leurs conditions
de travail et au même moment à
l'Assemblée la ministre essuyait le feu
roulant des des questions des députés
bonsoir Cécile RAC merci d'être là vous
êtes député apparenté renaissance du
valdoise ancienne enseignante et
principal de collège en scène
Saint-Denis bonsoir Rodrigo Arenas
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous député la
France insoumise de Paris ancien
président du premier syndicat de parents
d'élèves la FCPE vous êtes vous-même
enseignant et vous publiez je suis
parents d'élèves ah vous êtes parents
d'élèves citoyen d'ailleurs citoyen
députés parents vous raconte dans
passeur de monde qui vient juste de
sortir hein je crois aux éditions Parnas
bonsoir Grégory tuisa bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes cosesecrétaire SNES
FSU 93 professeur de français en lycée à
Saint-Denis enfin bonsoir Adrien Brachet
bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes journaliste éducation à Marianne
inutile de préciser que l'enseignant que
vous êtes peut intervenir quand vous le
souhaitez Patrick Obertelli vous en
parlez d'ailleurs he de la confiance de
dans l'école qui elle aussi se délite et
ce et ce des faits on commence par
planter le décor une ministre dans la
tourmente une deuxème journée d'action
c'est dans le reccap de Valérie Brochard
qu'on accue tout de
suite bonsoir bonsoir ma chère Valérie
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir à toutes et à
tous alors l'école l'école va mal ah oui
ça va mal he Myriam une nouvelle journée
de grève les profs sont encore descendus
dans la rue aujourd'hui un peu partout
en France voilà alors ça c'est pas les
ou voilà on va venir juste après voilà
c'était les images les images du du jour
des grévistes un peu partout en France
mais rappelez-vous he jeudi dernier ils
étaient déjà très en colère et très
mobilisés on comptait alors un
enseignant sur 5 en grève depuis la
colère ne retombe pas c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire puisqueaujourd'hui
d'après les syndicats les profs de
collège et lycées seraient mobilisés à
47 % bah ça fait presque un enseignant
sur deux aujourd'hui en grève pour
revendiquer une plus juste rémunération
évidemment mais aussi pour lutter contre
la politique éducative voulue par le
gouvernement regardez regardez cette
banderole voilà choc des savoirs égal
choc désespoir avec un petit jeu de mot
évidemment alors le choc des savoirs ce
sont des mesure en fait imaginz par
l'ancien ministre de l'Éducation vous
vous souvenez l'ancien ministre de
l'Éducation bah crois qu'on VO bien oui
un certain Gabriel Atal pour élever le
niveau des élèves j'avais lancé le choc
des savoirs il doit maintenant se
déployer le choc des savoirs c'est
assumer que tout le monde ne progresse
pas au même rythme que tout le monde n'a
pas les mêmes facilités ou les mêmes
difficultés la décision du redoublement
sera désormais à la main de l'équipe
pédagogique et les groupes de niveau
commenceront à se mettre en place dès
cette année dans nos collèges alors
c'est tout un plan qui avait été décliné
par Gabriel Attal en décembre dernier et
qui comprenait entre autres on les va
les retrouver des mesures qu'on va voilà
décliner ici suppression de l'URE de
technologie en 6e pour qui sera donc
remplacé par une heure de soutien ou
d'approfondissement les fameux groupes
de niveau dont Gabriel hatal vient de
parler la réduction du nombre d'heures
de la deuxième langue vivante pour de
donner aux élèves en difficulté et bien
des cours de mathématiques ou de
français en plus la réécriture des
programmes la labellisation des manuels
ce qui va contraindre les profs dans
leur liberté de choix d'Emmanuel bref
des idées qui ne plaisent pas du tout au
corps enseignant qui opposent au choc de
ces mesures ben le poids du réel pour
les syndicats les groupes de niveau vous
allez voir et bien c'est l'école du tri
social mais malgré tout malgré tout pour
l'instant et bien cette réforme du
second degré elle sera bien présentée au
Conseil supérieur de l'éducation mais
par qui qui va bien pouvoir porter ses
mesures et bien par la ministre de
l'Éducation bien sûr pas simple pour
Amélie oua Castera qui cumule deux
grèves à quelques jours d'intervalle et
il y a 3 heur à peine vous l'évoquez
myiam une audition ici même à
l'Assemblée nationale menée par la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation alors une commission dans
laquelle les élus n'avaient pas de
banderolle mais alors des questions qui
fusaient à bal réel regardez c'est une
audition bien particulière que nous
faisons aujourd'hui tant la situation
est totalement habituel et pour dire le
vrai assez critique alors je vous pose
directement la question madame la
ministre pensez-vous être à même de
pouvoir exercer votre fonction
ministérielle j'ai entendu que vouséiez
pour une école de l'épanouissement
républicain je voudrais savoir quel est
votre rapport aux valeurs de la
République quelle est la conception que
vous avez de la pédagogie de la laïcité
et de la pédagogie des valeurs de la
République chaque jour porte pour vous
son leeau de souffrance de casserole de
désaveux devant vous il n'y a qu'un mur
ou une porte de sortie
prenez-la waouh ouais effectivement
çaale journée pour la ministre mais bon
ça ira mieux demain ah ben non parce que
demain il y a il y a remanimement je
crois myiam je vous laisse en en
discuter sur le plateau est-ce qu'elle
sera toujours là mais c'est une question
évidemment qu'on va se poser ce soir
merci beaucoup valéré Brocha on va pas
parler que du cas ou des cas Cera mais
on commence forcément par par ça
personne qui devient quasiment
insupportable pour pour les syndicats
pour les enseignants on le voit très
bien dans les cortèges euh vous pensez
que c'est tenable encore
longtemps donc la question est adressée
Cécile RAC à
moi il faut avouer que la situation est
difficilement tenable aujourd'hui pour
un ministre d'éducation national qui
vient de prendre ses fonctions et qui
doit dans les prochains mois en effet
régulièrement discuter avec les
syndicats donc vous personnellement vous
souhaitez qu'elle parte aujourd'hui moi
la grande question que je me pose
c'est et j'en ai discuté d'ailleurs avec
avec avec les représentants de
différents syndicats c'est seront-ils
eux aussi CAPA de laisser passer en fait
ce qui ce qui ces polémiques par rapport
aux propos personnels sur la vie
personnel et sur les choix personnels de
la ministre Amélie ou cassera et pour
discuter du fond et
aujourd'hui la réponse que que que
j'entends sur le terrain c'est mais ça
sera difficile comment est-ce que on va
pouvoir discuter de du fond avec cette
ministre c'est intéressant parce que
vous êtes quand même dans le camp de la
majorité présidentielle c'est rare vous
dites elle ne peut plus exercer rue de
Grenelle c'est ce que vous dites vous
faites le porte-parole des syndicats
mais on a l'impression que c'est
clairement plus possible je me fais pas
le porte-parole des syndicats je me fais
aussi le porte-parole de de justement
d'un membre de la majorité qui a envie
que les choses avancent d'cord
aujourd'hui l'école elle est en très
grande difficulté on l'a jamais nié nous
avons toujours mené des politiques très
volontaires depuis
2017 sur sur l'école et aujourd'hui il
nous faut aussi avoir confiance très
clair vous n'êtes pas la seule dans le
camp présidentiel à dire ça à penser
comme ça c'est moi qui le vous le dis ce
soir alors les syndicats je viens vers
vous Grégory tuisa pour le SNES FSU
premier syndicat enseignant en collège
lycée elle doit partir écoutez si je
devais résumer en quelques mots
seulement la trajectoire de l'actuelle
ministre je commencerai d'abord par
changer l'intitulé de son porte
tefeuille on pourrait dire qu'elle a été
depuis son arrivée rue Grenel la
ministre de l'enseignement privé
confessionnel du contournement de
parcours sub de la non mixité sociale et
scolaire si on devait inventer une
nouvelle discipline au futur Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques 2024 je
pense qu'on pourrait inventer la chute
libre bon donc la confiance est
complètement rompue on peut pas la
jamais très grande mais ce qui n'était
déjà pas très important est désormais
totalement rompu en effet donc si elle
était confirmée demain parce qu'on
attend un remanement à priori annoncé
demain continuerait SN FSU à demander
son départ tout à fait d'autant plus que
ça signifierait qu'on continuerait avec
un portefeuille où l'éducation nationale
n'est pas un ministère de plein exercice
et pour les personnels de l'Éducation
nationale c'est un très gros problème
Rodrigo Arenas alors elle s'est pas
démonté euh elle a pas répondu sur les
polémiques personnelles mais elle a
déroulé sa feuille de route les les
réformes du choc du savoir on va on va
en parler et puis les moyens euh qui
sont substantiellement en hausse dans
l'éducation nationale euh elle s'est
bien défendu ou
pas vous savez quand on est dans une
audition de de l'Assemblée nationale on
n'est pas là pour se défendre on est là
pour répondre aux questions et en
l'occurrence il y a un certain nombre de
questions qui n'ont pas été répondues
par exemple moi je l'ai interrogé sur
l'uniforme qui est un vrai sujet ce qui
est emblématique de la politique qu'elle
veut mettre en uvre elle et celles et
ceux qui la soutiennent aujourd'hui et
il y a pas eu la réponse sur le coût
parce qu'on a eu quand même un vrai
sujet sur le projet de loi de finance
sur le financement de l'éducation
nationale et aujourd'hui quand
j'interroge sur les 2 milliards en plein
exercice elle me répond 2 millions donc
on est c'est pas sérieux donc il il y a
un vrai sujet sur la connaissance des
encore prête sur ces dossiers là elle
n'est pas prête vous diriez en tout cas
moi ce que j'ai j'ai ressenti c'est une
ministre qui est très pas aux abois mais
qui est qui est quand même très très
bousculé et qui récite des éléments de
langage qui finalement ne répondent pas
au vrai sujet qui est l'éducation
nationale et elle ne répond pas non plus
comme le dit mon voisin à ce qui fait
l'essence de l'éducation nationale ce
qui fait qu'elle ne connaît pas son
ministère c'est qu'on ne gère pas
l'éducation nationale sans associer les
corps intermédiaires c'est l'histoire de
la République c'est le contrat social
Aum
éitéme TER le tour de table vous vous
écoutez les acteurs à la fois off et on
donc vous savez vraiment ce ce qui se
passe et c'est un grand ministère
elle peut encore traverser cette crise
ou pas est-ce qu'elle peut être audible
si elle était maintenue ce qui est
certain c'est que bon Emmanuel Macron
fera le choix qu'il fait mais à la fois
sur le terrain à la fois sur le terrain
des enseignants mais aussi de la haute
administration d'éducation nationale et
sur le terrain politique c'estàd y
compris au sein de la majorité elle est
extrêmement fragilisée c'est-à-dire que
on l'a vu par exemple au cours de cette
audition les députés de la majorité ne
sont pas franchement venus la défendre
ils ont posé des questions très
consensuelles mais on sent qu'elle est
extrêmement fragilisé et je pense
qu'elle est aussi parce que il y a en
effet ces déclarations il y a tout tout
tout ce qui a déclenché le le le le la
colère et tout ce qui a ravivé la colère
et il y a aussi je pense cette erreur
initiale fondamentale dont parlait
Rodrigo Arenas qui est de nommer
quelqu'un dont ce n'est pas la dont
l'éducation n'est pas la spécialité à
l'heure où on dit que l'éducation doit
être la mère des batailles et à qui on
donne en même temps que l'éducation
nationale la gestion des Jeux Olympiques
en pleine année olympique ce qui en gros
arrive une fois tous les 100 ans mais on
lu alors les petites infos coulisses à
Marianne on passe aussi des coups de fil
à l'Élysée on sait que le Président on
va pas rester là-dessus tout le temps
hein mais quand même je termine n'aime
pas du tout agir sous la pression la
pression pour s'en débarrasser entre
guillemets elle est énorme est-ce que ça
y est la question se pose vraiment à
l'Élysée en tout cas oui en tout cas la
question se pose je je je suis pas dans
les petits papiers donc je sais pas
quels sont
les décidé le nom de François Baayou sur
circule beaucoup ce que des autres échos
que j'ai aussi mais alors ça ça se sait
depuis plusieurs jours c'est que Gabriel
Attal à Matignon voudrait plus ou moins
pouvoir passer à autre chose donc il y a
aussi gabrielal qui va essayer je pense
au vu de ce qui sort et des échos que
j'ai de mettre ça dans la balance il
faut un ministre fort pour la grande
cause de l'éducation ou au fond la
tutelle c'est déjà matigon Gabriel alors
ben juste justement je pense que ça
c'est une vraie question déjà c'estàdire
on a dit qu'on faisait de l'éducation la
priorité et au bout de 5 mois on a un
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
s'en va à matigon elle est là l'erreur
originale il est là d'une certaine
manière le péché originel c'est-à-dire
que vous ne pouvez pas dire c'est la mre
des batailles et au bout de 5 mois avec
un ministre en fait qui a à peine eu le
temps de lancer des réformes qui donc
n'a pas de bilan dire on passe à la
suite donc c'est vrai que maintenant on
se retrouve dans une situation quasi
impossible où soit vous allez devoir
avoir un ministre très fort mais qui
finalement va être va avoir une marge de
manœuvre très réduite soit vous lui
donnez une marge de manœuvre plus ample
mais à ce moment-là vous risquez
desésavouer Gabriel Attal donc la la
situation et l'équation du fait des
choix d'Emmanuel Macron est très
compliqué d'un tout petit mot et puis
ensuite on va sur le fond des dossiers
vous qui avez aculté cette notion de
confiance elle peut se rompre et c'est
définitif il y a de deux choses
euh la première c'est que comment
comment je vais le dire lorsqu'on
s'arrange un peu avec la réalité c'est
jamais payant et même quand c'est des
petits arrangements comme ça je crois
que c'est un enjeu fondamental c'est
d'être d'établir une relation de
confiance donc ça c'est première chose
deuxième chose c'est vrai que c'est
toujours très ennuyeux lorsque de
lorsqu'une personne est autant autant
désigné
euh comme responsable ou comme
représentatif de euh je trouve que j'ai
plutôt tendance à juger sur les actes et
prendre un peu de recul et pas tirer sur
l'ambulance ok alors on en vient à ce
choc des savoirs ce qui cristallise la
colère des enseignants ce sont outre les
moyens qu'ils attendent parce que
l'école va mal on va en parler mais ce
sont ces fameux groupe de niveaux Cécile
rilac est-ce que vous vous défendez
l'aménagement de la scolarité en
fonction des résultats est-ce que ces
groupes de niveau ne vont pas pénaliser
les les moins bons et créer une forme
d'école à deux vitesses alors c'est
justement pour éviter cet éco un des
d'écoes à deux vitesses qui quelque part
existe déjà ou aujourd'hui et ce n'est
pas nouveau c'est pas depuis Amélie ou
Cera depuis Gabri il était déjà là
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui on a des
élèves qui rentrent en 6e et qui
n'arrivent pas à résorber leur diff
et et en plus lorsque ils viennent d'un
milieu social on va dire défavorisé et
bien justement ces difficultés sont
accru et que c'est le collège qui
cristallise cette difficulté donc il y a
vraiment besoin au niveau du collège de
pouvoir différencier les apprentissages
pour permettre à chacun d'avancer à sa
vitesse comment ça va se passer parce
que c'est demain c'est septembre pour
les 6e et pour les 5è 15 élèves max
c'est ça dans quel de façon
expérimentale des petits groupes avec
qui devant quel enseignant est-ce qu'on
en a assez est-ce que vous avez le
caractère un peu opérationnel de la
mesure mais je je je pense que c'est la
difficulté que nous traversons
aujourd'hui c'est que le caractère
opérationnel justement aujourd'hui nous
ne l'avons pas ouis euh et là je le dis
d'une manière très franche et très
sincère parce qu'il aujourd'hui en fait
ce qui est demandé aux équipes euh
pédagogiques et particulièrement aux
chefs d'établissement c'est de faire
rentrer dans un volume horaire que nous
avons voté enfin pardon qui a été acté à
l'Assemblée nationale euh même s'il y a
une petite enveloppe une rallonge qui a
été donnée parce que ça c'est pour c'est
pas rien hein pour un budget c'est Prem
par rapport même au budget initial
c'est-à-dire au budget qui a qui qui a
été octroyé pour l'année 2024 il y a une
rallonge que Gabriel Atal a obtenu en
sus qui est environ si ma mémoire bonne
830 ETP mais aujourd'hui lorsqu'on
calcule 4h dem plus 4h dem0 c'est-à-dire
le volume horaire de français le volume
horaire de mathématiqu par élève donc ça
fait 9h élève si on veut en effet
dédoubler alors quand je dis dédoubler
c'est-à-dire proposer des groupes de
niveaux avec des maximums de 15 élèves
pour les élèves les plus en difficulté
et bien au bout du bout du bout du
compte on on arrive à plus un besoin de
plus de 2000 enseignants et aujourd'hui
euh il faut qu'on arrive à résoudre
cette équation comment est-ce que avec
830 postes je donc moi-même oui c'est
compliqué parce que vous êtes sur ce
plateau celle qui quand même devrait
avoir le plus de réponses mais voilà
mais c'est par que parce que non
seulement enfin nous avons des réponses
c'est-à-dire que moi je peux vous dire
oui il y a une nécessité oui c'est
important de pouvoir en effet faire ce
choc des savoirs oui c'est important de
proposer justement des groupes de niveau
oui c'est important de pouvoir
reproposer à la main des enseignants le
redoublement parce que c'est ce qui va
peut-être aujourd'hui redorer
l'institution alors peut-être avant de
savoir s'il y a les moyens parce que on
aura pas les résultats à ces questions
les réponses à ces questions sur ce
plateau sur le principe même 15 élèves
maximum pour les les plus en difficulté
est-ce que c'est pas tout simplement les
meilleures conditions pour progresser si
c'était possible Grégor pusia
alors la la réforme du choc des savoirs
c'est d'abord il y a deux dimensions
importantes c'est d'abord une réforme
qui est une réforme idéologique pourquoi
parce que le gouvernement pour la lancer
ne s'appuie sur aucun savoir académque
universitaire aujourd'hui les sciences
de l'éducation on peut lire Marie du
rubella on peut lire Sylvain Conac on
peut lire la revue française de
pédagogie une une note de synthèse qui
date de 2004 sur le sujet il est admis
partout par les chercheurs et
chercheuses en sciences de l'éducation
que la constitution de groupes homogène
est un frein au progrès dans les
apprentissages pour les élèves les plus
en difficulté pctuellement tiré par par
le haut par les meilleurs élèves c'est
exactement c'estàdire que ce qui fait la
capacité de progr dans les
apprentissages c'est de ne pas être
cantonné à des tâches répétitives et de
se confronter à des tâches de réflexion
des tâches dit complexe et ce n'est ce
n'est pas le cas lorsqu'on est dans un
groupe homogène alors il y a
l'homogénéité et puis il y a les petits
groupes les effectifs ça encore une fois
on va dire que les paramètres sont pas
tous réunis mais s'ils étaient réunis ça
vous pouvez pas vous opposer à cette
idée d'une petite de petit groupe
d'élèves avec un peu du surmesure pas si
c'était possible Rodrigo AR déjà ce que
font les enseignants en fait quand vous
êtes dans une classe avec un des élèves
qui sont hétérogènes soit par le capital
culturel des parents ou le capital
financier pour les accompagner quand les
absences non remplacées ne sont pas
assuré c'est évidemment ce que font les
enseignants ils font de la dentelle avec
les mom donc c'est ça la réalité du
terrain la question c'est que quand vous
avez des classes je pense dans le
général mais aussi dans le Pro vous avez
des gamins à plus de 30 élèves par
classe avec des des disparités énormes
avec des histoires personnelles aussi
qui sont compliquées et bien la question
des effectifs ne se pose pas que pour
les élèves qui sont en difficulté elle
se pose pour tous les élèves et là vous
allez avoir la question aussi de
l'harmonisation des notes entre les
différentes académies on va y venir mais
sur ces groupes de niveau parce que
c'est important ça ça change vraiment la
réalité d'une école tri social vraiment
évidemment que c'est un tri social et
vous allez le voir sur la réalité c'est
déjà le cas sur devoirfit devoirfit se
proposit déjà ces objectif rz-nous ce
que c'est ce dispositif devoir c'est des
dispositifs qui existent pour que les
élèves qui doivent faire les devoirs et
qui n'ont pas forcément l'accompagnement
à la maison pour le faire peuvent rester
au collège parce que c'est surtout le
collège qui est visé pour pouvoir faire
les devoirs sauf qu'aujourd'hui de par
le fait que vous avez des enseignants
qui sont dans des matières spéciales ils
ne peuvent pas aider les élèves dans des
matières dans lesqueles ils ne sont pas
autorisés entre guillemets
académiquement à pouvoir intervenir donc
vous avez inévitablement le fait que
devoir fait devient un lieu où on fait
les devoirs mais on ne fait pas
progresser l'élève parce qu'un
enseignant de français quel rapport avec
les groupes de niveau parce que c'est
exactement la même philosophie quand
vous avez pas les moyens de ne mettre en
œuvre et que vous n'avez pas atteint
l'objectif avec devoir fait vous ne
pourrez pas non plus l'atteindre avec
les groupes de niveau parce que ce sont
les mêmes enseignants les mêmes
effectifs les mêmes établissements avec
le même avec les mêmes résultats qui
seront finalement un échec patenté et en
donnant un espoir d' au parents qui sera
désastreux parce que les parents feront
confiance à quelque chose qui n'existera
pas d'ord Adrien Brachet comment vous
analysez la philosophie de de ces mesure
on a l'impression qu'on veut introduire
de la flexibilité un peu plus de
surmesure d'aménager aussi le temps
scolaire parfois faire plus de savoirs
fondamentaux math français au détriment
temporaire d'autres disciplines alors
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'il faut
comprendre politiquement dans dans cette
visionquement politiquement le le le le
sentiment que j'ai en tant que
journaliste c'est qu'il y a eu de la
part de Gabriel la tal beaucoup de
communication pour tenter de répondre à
des demandes qui en effet existent dans
l'opinion d'autorité de de d'exigence de
respect du professeur et que donc il a
voulu envoyer toute une série de signaux
y compris par exemple sur la question du
redoublement en disant on va donner le
dernier mot aux enseign sera plus bout
voilà mais il y a beaucoup de
communication là-dedans et en effet ce
qu'on constate c'est que c'est
visiblement une réforme quoi une série
de mesures mal ficelées
les moyens sur le terrain n'y sont
visiblement pas et pour rejoindre ce
qu'on disait sur la recherche
scientifique en effet la recherche
scientifique est très sceptique sur les
groupes de niveau sauf si en effet on
fait des regroupements ponctuels de
manière fluide le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui avec les niveaux avec les
moyens qu'on a il y a très peu de chance
qu'on arrive à cette fluidité ou à ce
pour se donner une idée de la pénuerie
et d'enseignant à peu près 50 % 48 %
combien de de d'établissements manque de
prof au au dernier concours enseignant
pour donner un ordre d'idée il y avait
plus de 3000 postes non pourvus avec
certaines disciplines dans le second
degré qui sont particulièrement concerné
et dans le premier degré là c'est aussi
très inquiétant puis qu'il y a des vrais
inégalités géographiques certaines
académies qui concentrent toutes les
difficultés je pense à l'Académie de
versaill 68 % j'ai ça voilà l'académie
de Paris un petit peu et la Guyane aussi
manque d'enseignant alors j'entends le
mot temporaire si les chercheurs
s'accordent à dire que les groupes
homogènes dans la durée si ça fossilise
les gens euh dans dans un enseignement
spécifique ça ça ça les ça les bloque en
revanche si c'est ponctuel c'est quoi
les les résultats des études ça ça peut
marcher sur des difficultés ponctuelles
alors là c'est moi pour répondre en tant
que la ancienne chef d'établissement et
ancienne
professeur le le le le regroupement par
niveau temporaire c'est-à-dire sur une
période donnée parce qu'il y a eu une
évaluation et on a évalué un besoin et
qu'on va justement prendre un groupe
d'élèves qui va avoir un besoin
particulier et on va y répondre sur une
séquence peut-être de 5 à 6 semaines ça
peut avoir en effet un effet bénéfique
d'autant plus si il est à effectif ça ça
n'existe pas par le tut par cours de
soutien pourquoi j'en parle aussi
facilement c'est parce que en tant que
chef d'établissement c'est quelque chose
que j'ai essayer de mettre en place et
que j'avais réussi à mettre en place
avec mon équipe de mathématiques à en sc
saintis où justement les professeurs
donc des de mathématiques avaient
accepté de travailler quasiment tous
ensemble euh sur les classes de 6e pour
euh répondre à à des besoins spécifiques
à des moments mais ça ne se passait pas
sur la totalité des 4h et demi
d'enseignement de mathématique
c'est-à-dire que ils avaient leur groupe
classe et donc ensuite ils prenaient sur
un volume horaire d'une heure euh et
c'était et c'était un véritable projet
pédagogique donc sur le fond il il peut
ça peut être très intéressant pour les
élèves pour les accompagner maintenant
ça demande aussi un accompagnement de la
part des enseignants parce que ça
demande aussi un très gros
investissement de la part des équipes
qui doivent à ce moment-là aussi et bien
être complètement calé en terme de
programme vous savez que tous les
enseignants n'avancent pas à la même
vitesse parce que les groupes justement
sont hétérogènes que derrière quand on
veut faire une évaluation monsieur
Arenas vous en parliez c'est le niveau
comment comment est-ce qu'on peut
harmoniser alors justement puisque vous
parlez de l'évaluation on on a bien vu
le la philosophie il y a des priorités
c'est les mathématiques le français et
au fond faire des des groupes de niveau
ponctuel sur
l'évaluation pour les pour les savoir la
suppression du correctif
académique ça vous y êtes plutôt
favorable ces groupes dans lequel les
enseignants devaent harmoniser soit pour
le brevet soit pour le bac les notes
pour arriver à certains pourcentages ça
a été critiqué par les enseignants
eux-mêmes qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ça a été critiqué mais cette cette
mesure en fait c'est une mesure de
façade c'est une mesure cosmétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait croire à la
communauté enseignante et aux équipes
professionnelles dans les établissements
scolaires que qu'elles vont pouvoir de
nouveau se saisir de leur métier et
faire redevenir le métier d'enseignant
d'enseignante un métier de conception la
réalité elle n'est pas ça puisque on dit
à la fois qu'on redonne du pouvoir aux
enseignants aux enseignantes pour qu'ils
aient la dernière décision le dernier
mot et en même temps on prépare des
manuels labellisés où est la logique
là-dedans c'est-à-dire que soit on a une
institution verticale directive soit on
a
effectivement ement une une communauté
enseignante qui est qui est à l'origine
et à la base d'initiative pédagogique
après moi je voulais juste revenir
quelques quelques petites secondes sur
la réalité des chiffres c'est important
je serai très court on nous dit que
cette ce choc des savoirs et ces groupes
de
niveau c'est c'est l'installation
effectivement de groupe de de d'élèves
effectifs réduits sauf que ça se fait au
détriment d'autres disciplines et
d'autres dispositifs madame la députée
en parlait qu'on appelle
l'accompagnement pédagogique par exemple
c'est-à-dire ponctuellement sur
certaines disciplines on utilisait ce
qu'on appelle dans les collèges la
marche d'autonomie c'est-à-dire le pot
commun des établissements pour mettre en
place des dispositifs à la main des
équipes enseignantes bien entendu sous
l'autorité des chefs d'établissement
mais dans le cadre d'un dialogue
vraiment concerté tel qu'on tel qu'on
souhaite ce
n'est puisen fait cette mesure la mesure
qui est annoncé des groupes des groupes
de niveau n'est pas financée par Gabriel
tal puis Amélie ou DEA casterra elle
n'est pas financée parce que en fait on
reprend sur les 2330 équivalent en plein
les 2330 postes on en reprend 1500 en
enlevant par exemple une heure de cours
aux élèves de 6e je suis pas convaincu
pour faire progresser les le cours de
LV2 c'est ça c'est le le la suppression
de la technologie cette cette mesure
scandaleuse elle est maintenue et les
élèves de 6e l'an prochain la rentrée
2024 n'auront plus que 25 heures de
cours et non pas 26 comme les autres
niveaux au sein du collège donc ça veut
dire qu'on a des mesures de
redéploiement vous le soullignez
d'ailleurs ce weekend dans les écho hein
il me semble en en évoquant des des des
mesures à moyen constant en réalité vous
avez bien les 830 équivalent en plein en
plus mais on ne sait pas s'ils seront
pérennes et surtout la plupart des
mesures en fait ne sont pas financées
donc elles sont financées par
l'utilisation par les établissements
eux-mêmes de leur propre enveloppe et
donc au détriment du latin des langues
vivantes d'autres dispositifs alors on
on a tous en tête le classement Piz je
me fais un peu l'avocat du diable parce
que voilà il faut pouvoir aussi être
dans dans un dans un dialogue
contradictoire mais Rodrigo Arenas pizza
c'est la cata pour le dire simplement
pour la France en mathématique mais
aussi en français et la philosophie de
des pouvoirs publics c'est de de de
redonner cette priorité du fondamental
alors j'entends bien les langues
vivantes l'histoire les humanités comme
on disait dans le temps mais mais s'il y
a une priorité c'est aussi un choix
pédagogique al d'abord tout ce dont on
est en train de parler c'est une
exigence qui est faite à l'école
publique d'accord l'école privée est
toujours la grande absente de ces
questionsl alors qu' c'est précisément
le lieu organisationnel institutionnel
dans lequel on organise justement cette
sécession scolaire qui se traduit aussi
par séation sociale et dans lequel
madame oua casterra a été au cœur de la
polémique c'est l'instrumentalisation
des peurs des parents pour justifier des
choix personnels de ce que moi j'appelle
la réocratie de la mise en connexion
d'élèves qui finalement sont destinés à
à maintenir ce fr soumise la position
est claire c'est qu'on supprime
l'enseignement privé c'est ça non pas du
tout pu il y a une loi qui existe en
France qui permet aux parents de choisir
l'établissement de leur choix c'est la
c'est la Charte de la laïcité qui permet
justement de choisir un enseignement
professionnel nous ce que nous disons
c'est qu'aujourd'hui puisque l'école
publique est accus de tous les mots qui
a besoin d'enseignant qui a besoin de
financement qui a besoin de réflexion
qui a besoin d'associer les les
enseignants les parents d'élèves et les
élèves aussi à la réflexion d' nouvelle
école et bien il faut des moyens
financiers donc évidemment l'argent
public doit être réservé à l'école
publique et ça va ça veut dire remettre
en question trop la fondamentale de
notre société de notre pays qui sont
Fallou Debré et Carl c'est ça le sujet
aujourd'hui donc quand vous dites ce que
vouses en train de lire ce qu'on est ce
qu'on est en train de mettre en œuvre
quand on parle d'harmonisation des notes
et tout ça c'est que les enseignants
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils mettent deux
points de plus aux élèves c'est parce
que on ne peut pas noter de la même
façon un élève qui est dans un quartier
prioritaire sur lequel il est attendu
sur des savoirs fondamentaux avec des
codes qu'ils n'ont pas qu'un élève qui
les a je vous très schématiquement moi
je suis député de Paris on ne peut pas
interroger un élève qui va aller au
Louvre toutes les semaines avec ses
parents avec un élève qui n'ira jamais
par contre c'est ce qu'on attend d'ux
d'un point de vue du système scolaire
donc ces deux points c'est la façon de
compenser le manque de capital culturel
que ces enfants n'ont pas et c'est bien
le problème de l'école de la République
c'est qu'onévalue pas les enfants de la
même façon et qu'on introduit un biais
cognitif qui est très important et moi
je peux vous en parler pour la s s où on
ne peut pas le fameux correctif vous
vous voulez le le maintenir on avance
sur l'autorité le mot a été prononcer
l'uniforme dans tout ça vous allez nous
dire ce que ce que vous en pensez les
établissements volontaires à
l'expérimentation doivent obtenir vous
le savez la Val du conseil
d'administration ou du conseil d'école
certains parents d'élèves collégiens
lycéens réfractaaires ont déjà mis à mal
la liste du ministère explication avec
ce sujet des équipes de France
Télé
voilà à quoi pourrait ressembler la
tenue unique dans la région au verg
ronalpe bleu marine avec le logo de la
région et celui de l'établissement sans
oublier le drapeau français TR polos et
de pulls par élève entièrement financés
par la
Région l'uniforme va pouvoir lutter
contre le harcèlement gommer certaines
différences et également rendre la vie
plus facile au chefs d'établissement de
voir la tenue autorisée non autorisée C
lycées de la région devrai tenter l'ex
expérience une initiative qui divise les
élèves et professeurs interrogés devant
cet établissement lyonnais ça permet
justement de de mettre sur un pied
d'égalité vraiment tout le monde moi je
suis plutôt contre parce que nos habiers
c'est une façon de nous exprimer de de
voir comment enfin de c'est notre
caractère en fait c'est notre c'est
comment on est certaines choses seraient
moins visibles comme la pauvreté de
certains peut-être donc voilà des élèves
qui qui ont des vêtements pas forcément
très propres ou qui se changent pas
forcément tout ça on le verrait
peut-être moins en France la tenue
unique sera expérimentée dans une
centaine d'établissements primaires
collèges et lycées publics et privés sur
la base du volontariat à Balma dans la
banlieue de Toulouse deux écoles
primaires publiques sont candidate pour
tester la tenue unique à partir de
septembre un ensemble gratuit pour les
familles promis par le maire les tenues
seront fournis par les collectivités
financé à 50 % par l'État 50 % par les
collectivités donc en l'occurrence nous
c'est la ville donc 50 % par la ville
dans une limite de 200 € par enfant
au-delà du coût de cette expérimentation
ce syndicat de proviseur doute de
l'efficacité de la tenue unique la
question n'est pas de la celle de la
tenue he mais effectivement celle du
comportement global des élèves qui doit
se traiter non pas à coup d'uniforme
hein donc mais à travers effectivement
d'autres
mesures et et notamment celle de la
mixité sociale scolaire l'uniforme est
une tradition dans certains territoires
d'outrem notamment aux Antilles l'île de
la Réunion elle va lancer
l'expérimentation dans l'un de ses
collèges ailleurs le test débutera en
septembre pour une durée de 2 ans Adrien
Brachet vous diriez qu'elle est bien en
manchée cette expérimentation on a vu
qu'il y a pas pas mal d'établissements
où c'est plus compliqué parce que
finalement les parents ne sont sont pas
forcément d'accord oui c'est bah
d'ailleurs c'est ce queon dit en off y
compris au sein du ministère de
l'éducation nationale c'est qu'il y a
plein de collectivités local ou
territorial qui dès que la proposition
d'expérimentation a été faite se sont
tout de suite porté candidates et on se
rend compte au fur à mesure qu'il y a
beaucoup d'établissements dans lesquels
vous avez notamment des crisp passions
de la part de parents d'élèves ou
d'élèves la difficult pour quelle raison
on sait déjà alors il a alors il y a a a
il y a des raisons d'un point de vue
très pratique il y a il y a il peut y
avoir des raison financière même si pour
l'instant il y a pas de participation
des parents dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation mais il pourrait y en
avoir s'il y avait général ation mais il
y a aussi plus largement des raisons
politiques et peut-être que l'uniforme
peut être pertinent dans certains cas on
l'a vu en outreem ça peut fonctionner
dans certains établissements qui on font
le choix même il compris dans
l'enseignement professionnel vous avez
des tenues professionnelles et des
élèves qui sont très fiers de les porter
mais c'est difficile d'en faire comme
est en train d'en faire Emmanuel Macron
et le gouvernement c'est une sorte de
priorité politique c'est c'est c'est
c'est on peut comprendre que derrière
les enseignants et les parents quand
vous dites la priorité c'est l'uniforme
ont l'impression c'est pe lâ c'est de la
communication parce que quand on parle
de l'uniforme on parle pas de la
question centrale de la formation des
enseignants peutêtre qu'on en parlera de
la question de la pénurie des
enseignants de de de la question des
conditions de travail des enseignants la
question du niveau de la question de la
laïcité
voyez faire une de totem politique voilà
le cœur des des sujets mais c'est vrai
que cette feuille de route
présidentielle nousous nous fait vous
vous fait commenter cette cette uniforme
la tenue unique c'est pas l'alpha et
l'oméga pour résoudre les problèmes de
ce c'est C RAC non ça c'est clair que
c'est pas l'alpha et et l'oméga
d'ailleurs nous au groupe de au sein de
la majorité c'est un sujet que nous
avons traité puisque pour rappel il y a
une proposition de loi qui a été qui
avait été proposée donc il y a
maintenant un an et au au niveau de la
majorité on s'est on s'est
questionné à savoir justement est-ce que
c'était une bonne ou une pas bonne idée
euh bonne ou pas bonne idée dans le sens
est-ce que ça doit être généralisé et la
question posé par la PPL dont je vous
parle c'était de la rendre obligatoire
et les conclusions auxquelles ce groupe
de travail était arrivé c'était que si
il doit y
avoir un uniforme la base c'est qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une acceptation et de
la compréhension de à quoi sert ou cette
tenue unique ou cette uniforme ou cette
tenue professionnelle vous l'avez dit
Monsieur Brachet donc s'il n'y a pas une
concertation entre les parents les
enseignants et bien entendu les élèves
qui sont à minima associé parce que là
c'est pareil on nassocie pas un élève de
primaire de maternelle de la même
manière qu'on associe un lycéen à ce
type de discussion donc s'il n'y a pas
cette réflexion seulement les
établissements qui doivent être
volontaires mais embarquer tous les
publics très cl là-dessus c'est
cosmétiqu vous allez me dire mais ça
peut recréer du de la cohésion c'est un
suj sujet de Fond de la vision qu'on a
de l'enfant de l'adolescent c'est pas
une tenue unique c'est un uniforme faut
le dire les M clairement et la question
qui se pose c'est d'ailleurs l'interview
vous avez faite c'est que toutes les
questions qu'on veut aborder à travers
cette mesure là n'est pas une solution
aucun des pays au monde qui met en place
l'uniforme ne règle la question du
harcellement ne règle la question des
égalités sociales ne règle la question
de l'autorité ou de l'autoritarisme ça
ne règle au rien moi je viens d'Amérique
du Sud je peux vous dire que l'uniforme
et la règle il y a du harcèlement il y a
des inégalités sociales il y a même des
signes distinctifs au-delà des uniformes
qui le font par contre ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que cette mesure en déroulement
complet va coûter 2 milliards d'euros
moi je préfère les mettre allez je du
gouvernement je préfère les mettre dans
les cours de soutien pour les élèves qui
ont difficultés en math en français et
en langue et ça sera pas le cas vous
aurez le le mot de la fin Grégory Tiza
sur l'uniforme écoutez 2 milliards
d'euros moi je mets ça un titre
d'exemple en rapport avec ce que demande
par exempleinter syndical pour l'école
publique en scène Saint-Denis hein pour
avoir de réels moyens pour l'école
publique on a chiffré ça à 360 million
d'euros 5000 postes d'enseignants et
d'enseignantes 175 CPE des assistants
d'éducation des assistants pédagogiques
des as aussi bien entendu pour
accompagner les les enfants en situation
de handicap cap la 2 milliards pour
l'uniforme ça signifie en gros qu'on
continue la logique après il faut
reconnaître alléiser une certaine
logique en décembre 2018 il y avait des
lycéens des lycéennes qui avaient été
mis à genou à Manent la jolie au son
deun classe qui se tient sage c'est sans
doute la vision de l'école que défend
actuellement le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire une école mise au pas et
caporalisée c'est dit on aura entendu
les priorités d' l'iforme existe à
Stanislas comme vous le savez et aussi
dans l'établissement préfér dernière
petite claque au passage merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu débattre il fait que
commencer ce débat sur l'école et il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de sujet vous restez
avec moi Patrick Bertelli dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir Cécilia gabizon
s'est penché sur la sexualité en berne
des Français les soldes ça sert encore à
quelque chose s'interroge Fanny
guinochet et puis de quoi nous
parlez-vous dans Bourbon Express
Stéphanie Despierre ce soir l'hommage
aux victimes du 7 octobre demain aux
Invalides faut-il que la France
insoumise y participe à tout à l'heure
mesdames mais d'abord on va plonger dans
votre livre Patrick auertelli la
confiance nouvel horizon social vous
avez demandé à toute une série de d'
acteurs de terrain des médecins des
préfets des avocats de réfléchir à ce
lien de confiance des Français qui ne
cessent de s'étioler vis-à-vis des
institutions de la justice des
journalistes regardez c'est dans
l'invitation d'El modingava interview
juste
après si on vous invite Patrick
auertelli c'est pour parler confiance la
confiance dont manque cruellement les
Français dans la politique dans dans la
justice ou dans les médias et pourtant
la confiance est pour vous la base
fondamentale du fonctionnement de nos
sociétés Patrick aubertelli vous êtes
professeur à l'Université Paris saclai
chercheur au laboratoire formation du
Centre national des arts et métiers vos
thématiques la démocratie comment mieux
faire société la confiance comment avoir
confiance quand les crises se succèdent
voire se superpos crise climatique crise
sanitaire conflit aux portes de l'Europe
les hommes et les femmes politiques ont
bien conscience que cette donne
déstabilise les Français au fond le
monde d'hier est en train de
s'effacer l'ordre international que nous
connaissions est
bousculé la guerre revient nous vivons
nous le savons aussi la crise du modèle
démocratique en France en Europe et dans
beaucoup d'autres pays la crise
climatique provoque des inquiétudes et
pousse à des transitions qui divisent
parfois nos pays mais on le voit partout
là aussi en Europe et l'irruption de
nouvelles technologies bouleverse
beaucoup de nos repères le diagnostic
est posé mais les remède difficile à
trouver dans sa dernière enquête le
cvpof révèle les sentiments des Français
à l'égard de la politique en premier
lieu la méfiance loin devant le dégoût
l'intérêt l'ennui et l'espoir une des
causes que vous mettez en avant pour
expliquer cette défiance ce sont les
doutes suscités par la gestion des
crises sanitaires Tchernobyl sans
contaminé vache folle et plus récemment
crise du covid nombre de Français ont le
sentiment que le gouvernement leur a
caché des choses alors si la confiance
ne se décrète pas mais se gagne Patrick
aubertelli une question ce
soir comment retisser le lien de
confiance entre les Français et leurs
institutions le remède docteur Robert
le le remèdeut d'abord le d'abord faire
un un const et peut-être rappeler encore
quelques chiffres même sils ont déjà été
été posés si on regarde l'enquête svipov
qui est de février 2023 donc comm
relativement
récente la confiance des Français dans
la justice est de 44 % sur la justice h
de tous les services publics c'est le
plus bas c'est pas le plus bas c'est
c'est un des un des un des plus bas la
la gendarmerie et la police sont
préservé mais par exemple les banques
sont à 38 % les syndicat à 36 % les
médias 28 % et puis les politiques à 16
% alors on va d'ailleurs y revenir dans
le détail parce qu'on a préparé
justement à partir de cette enquête du
svpu des tableaux peut-être pour pour
bien comprendre qu'est-ce que la
confiance comment rapidement vous
définissez ce terme la la confiance
c'est ce qui est mis en place lorsque il
y a de l'incertitude et des risques
c'est pour ça que vous avez rappelé
qu'il il y a un contexte
là politique il y a un contexte
climatique avec des questions majeures
pour chacun que sera l'Europe dans 5 ans
est-ce que notre système de retraite est
est suffisamment par répartition est
suffisamment robuste et cetera et cetera
est-ce que vous diriez que c'est parce
que l'époque que nous traversons le
monde dans lequel on est est
particulièrement anxiogène incertain sur
l'avenir que la confiance est à ce point
je n'ose pas dire rompue mais très très
mauvaise très basse ou est-ce que la
crise de confiance remonte à bien plus
long
elle a elle a débuté vers les années 70
avec la crise économique et avec la
perte des je dirais des grands récit
collectifs qui qui projette vers un
avenir
positif la croyance dans le progrès et
dans le Progrès socialement favorable
pour tous et cetera voilà mais par
contre la crise est d'une particulière
actualité ce que je peux dire c'est
quand même si il y a pas d'incertitude
il y a pas de mais il y a pas besoin de
confiance si tout est maîtrisé et c'est
c'est ça le cœur H HM donc la variable
c'est l'incertitude plus l'incertitude
est grande plus la confiance est faible
absolument et avec les risques qui sont
qui sont inhérant vous dites pas
défiance société de la défiance vous
dites confiance
éclatée c'est la même chose c'est
différent il y a il y a une défiance qui
se généralise dans un ensemble de de
champs et de façon transversale c'est
pour ça qu'on a fait cet ouvrage de avec
ce regard mul multiple mais il y a des
îlos de confiance qui peuvent être qui
peuvent être maintenus par exemple les
associations on a une chance
merveilleuse en France d'avoir des
associations extrêmement active dont on
devrait s'aspirer davantage il sont
capables d'aller rechercher des gens qui
sont vraiment en marginalité sociale en
difficulté donc les plus à même de ne
pas avoir confiance sont capable de et
ça les Français y tiennent et gardent ce
lien on va aller assez vite sur la
science toujours à partir du cvipof
c'est assez surprenant parce que vous
parliez du covid de des autorités
sanitaires en qui on a moins confiance
on a vu ce qui s'est passé sur le vaccin
pendant pendant l'épidémie globalement
les les Français 80 % ont confiance dans
la science et en même temps on l'a vu
pendant le covid ça a été très très très
compliqué pour les politiques de se
voilà de réussir à créer du commun sur
la manière d'en
sortir prenons l'exemple du du covid
alors il y a déjà il y a déjà plusieurs
choses c'est la façon dont c'est dont
est géré cette incertitude alors ça
montre aussi que la vous avez des
régimes autoritaires comme la Chine
comme le Brésil de bolsonaro qui eux ont
ont géré le plus mal avec les les
conséquences que que l'on sait C cette
crise du covid c'est-à-dire que pour
gérer la complexité on a besoin de nos
démocraties on a besoin de soutenir mais
pourquoi est-ce que
cette les régimes autoritaires
augmentent montent actuellement c'est
parce que ça a un effet de de
réassurance on croit que ça va réduire
l'incertitude mais c'est vers ça qu'on
va ouis c'est l'homme fort qui permet de
combler justement c'est très inégal
incertitude du ou pardon sur le sur le
le le covid un endroit où
particulièrement ça n'a pas été suivi
c'est en Guadeloupe et pourquoi parce
que il y a eu la crise du du chord d'con
et il y a eu les mensonges qui étaient
derrière voyez je voudrais qu'on parle
de de nos institutions c'est intéressant
parce que vous l'avez mentionné quand on
regarde les services publics les
autorités de l'État censé nous protéger
les hôpitaux l'école ça reste assez
élevé la police l'armée aussi c'est on
l'a dit la confiance dans la justice qui
est quand même assez faible hein il y a
moins d'un Français sur deux qui ont
confiance dans dans leur justice et si
on prend les politiques les partis
politiques on va les voir s'afficher
alors là ça dégringole c'est
véritablement on parlera des Médi a tout
à l'heure mais en en gros entre les
journalistes et les politiques on est
vraiment la cible de toutes les
défiances qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
alors on a fait le Paris dans cet
ouvrage en interme souvant des gens qui
ont vraiment les connaissances
approfondies dans des domaines
différents de puisque le problème est
transversal on interroge les différentes
dimensions et on regarde si s'il y a une
dimension si des dimensions apparaissent
on a identifié trois majeurs la première
c'est la préservation des biens commun
préservation des bienens communs
et il faut montrer pour ça être cohérent
entre les paroles et les actes il faut
aussi que les objectifs autour des biens
communs soient clairs et soi partagés et
puis il est nécessaire d'avoir une une
de prouver son efficacité h h et
maintenant de plus en plus on n plus
dans une attente d'une efficacité vers
les politiques de l'immédiaté mais aussi
sur le moyen et long terme pour les
générations et toute la difficulté avec
le réchauffement climatique on a
l'impression à vous lire que d'une
certaine façon c'est la proximité
l'échelle locale et pourquoi pas
d'ailleurs les techniques managériales
de la petite entreprise les Français ont
bien plus confiant dans les petites
entreprises que dans les grands groupes
qui pourraient permettre de de retisser
le lien est-ce que il faut s'inspirer de
des organisations des des entreprises
pour pour trouver pour trouver une
solution ou ou au contraire PRS rebattir
un lien avec les les élus les
représentants non
je si le premier point c'est
effectivement d'avoir retrouvé les biens
communs il y a un autre point qui est
fondamental c'est on peut pas parler
d'un rapport à la démocratie d'un
rapport à la confiance si les gens ne
sont pas acteurs quand vous êtes passif
face à une situation et à l'incertitude
là vous l'association de du citoyen à la
décision publique on le voit dans les
vot ation on le voit aussi tout
simplement quand il y a des comités de
quartier où les gens viennent constater
proposer ça c'est la solution le local
jusqu'au sommet la confiance ne viendra
jamais d'en haut la la confiance peut
venir d'en haut mais un État
centralisé qui décide de tout c'est plus
c'est absolument plus possible sur la
complexité il faut s'appuyer sur les
problématiques locales il faut les faire
remonter il faut faire coagir les
acteurs les acteurs privé les acteurs
publics et cetera merci beaucoup Patrick
Bertelli je renvoie à cet ouvrage
collectif que vous avez codirigé aux
éditions du champ sociale la confiance
nouvel horizon social le mot de contrat
social n'est pas un gros mot et il faut
le le reconstruire si je peux rajouter
juste un tout petit point ridement parce
que vous allez devoir réagir à nos
chroniqueuse ce soir allez-y très très
vite c'est que le livre n'a pas été fait
pour pour être euu comme tel c'est
l'intention c'est de mettre en débat
cette question c'estàdire
on peut dire oui la confiance on peut la
déplorer le manque de confiance et
cetera mais c'est un objet et c'est un
objet majeur en politique j'espère que
nous y avons contribué ce soir allez
c'est l'heure des affranchis vous allez
pouvoir réagir à leur parti prix on les
accueille tout de suite et bonsoir
mesdames Fanny guinochet France Info la
matinale pour l'économie et Cécilia
Gabison de l'agence ETX bienvenue à vous
on commence par bonbon Express comme
chaque soir l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée Stéphanie des pierres ce
soir pour nous la raconter Stéphanie
bonsoir bonsoir et ce soir je vous
raconte l'histoire d'une polémique à
propos de l'Hommage aux 42 victimes
françaises de l'attaque du 7 octobre
hommage prévu demain aux Invalides une
polémique qui tient en une question la
France insoumise doit-elle y participer
non répondent cinq familles de victimes
elles ont même écrit à Emmanuel Macron
pour lui demander de ne pas convier le
parti de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans leur
courrier elles écrivent entre indécence
absence de respect relativisme et
négationnisme la France insoumise et ses
porte-paroles se sont illustrés par des
propos gravissimes depuis pogrom du 7
octobre selon ses proches des tués les
insoumis n'auraient donc pas leur place
à la cérémonie de demain aux Invalides
c'est aussi l' vie de Sylvain Maillard
le président du groupe Renaissance je
pense que ce n'est pas la place de la
France insoumise d'être à cet hommage
c'est un hommage aux victimes victimes
françaises du 7 octobre un drame absolu
un attentat islamiste sur lequel la
France insoumise n'a pas clairement
condamné toujours été ambigu on a eu
même le S sentiment qu'ils étaient les
avocats du Hamas et pourtant mat Panau
la présidente du groupe insoui sera bien
présente à l'hommage de demain aux
Invalides oui elle l'a confirmé ce matin
elle sera accompagnée de plusieurs
députés dont manuel bonpard le numéro 1
de la France insoumise interrogé en
conférence de presse ce matin elle
essaie d'éteindre la polémique avec une
réponse assez lapidaire nous avons été
invités à cet hommage national par le
Président de la République et je veux
dire ici solennellement que les
polémiques doivent s'arrêter quand la
Nation toute entière rend hommage aux
morts et la polémique ne s'est pas
arrêté elle s'est même invité lors de la
séance de question au gouvernement cet
après-midi par la voix de meilleur Habib
dont la circonscription comprend Israël
le député a parenté les républicains
cibleent très violemment les insoumis et
la porte-parole du gouvernement lui
répond qui imagine Bousquet Papon
fauisson participer à l'hommage annuel
de la rafle du veldive car c'est cela
dont il s'agit de grâce qu'ils a un
sursaut de décence et d'humanité envers
les victimes pour ne pas s'imposer à à
l'hommage pas aux Invalides en ce temp
républicain Monsieur le Premier Ministre
pourquoi les avoir invités si le
protocole prévoit d'inviter tous les
responsables politiques chacun chacun
appréciera l'opportunité ou non de sa
présence puisque les familles se sont
exprimées une manière de dire aux
insoumis qu'il ne devrait pas y aller
mais la ministre ne peut pas le dire
clairement parce que personne pas même
le président de la République ne peut
interdire à un parlementaire de
participer à une cérémonie républicaine
qu'il soit d'extrême gauche ou d' droite
merci beaucoup Stéphanie on reviendra
d'ailleurs sur cet hommage demain soir
dans notre débat sur LCP Fannie sans
transition oui sans transition sol c'est
fini ça s'arrête aujourd'hui vous
vouliez dresser le bilan il est il est
pas bon il est à il est pas très très
bon puisque on a des baisses de de vente
jusqu'à moin 30 % alors ça dépend
évidemment des commerçants mais quand
même c'est pas très brillant et c'est
surtout dans l'abement que ces
commerçants sont amers parce que que ce
soit dans la chaussure ou et et cetera
vous voyez il y a un certain nombre
d'enseignes qui mettent la clé sous la
porte on a encore appris tout à l'heure
que ikaks supprimait des magasins et ça
fait suite à kamaux KUKA enfin la série
est très longue c'est vraiment l'catombe
alors les professionnels ne s'y
retrouvent plus et puis en plus c'est
vrai que pas de chance pour eux mais ces
derniers temps du côté des au moment des
soldes il y a eu souvent des conflits
sociaux là on a eu le conflit avec les
agriculteurs l'année précédente à cette
même période c'était les la contre la
réforme des ite donc c'est vrai que le
système des soldes mériterait une petite
refronte alors comment il faudrait il
faudrait changer quoi alors déjà il y a
un petit souci et quand vous interrogez
les consommateurs ils vous le disent en
fait on sait pas exactement quand est-ce
qu'il y a les soldes parce qu'il y a des
promos tout le temps toute l'année que
ce soit des ventes privées des Black
Friday enfin on est un peu perdu et donc
du coup bah forcément les soldes perdent
de leur
attrait et les commerçants demandent
d'ailleurs un certain nombre au
gouvernement de revoir ces c'est rabetis
possible tout au long de l'année et puis
la durée des soldes 4 semaines fixé par
arrêté ministériel là aussi les
commerçants disent on n pas le temps de
mettre en en rayon que déjà il faut
brader nos nos vêtements ou nos produits
ça ne colle plus finalement au
calendrier des saisons et le e-commerce
qui vient jouer les concurrents on peut
mesurer l'effet alors effectivement là
c'est la la lame de fond le e-commerce
parce que là aussi hein les plateformes
font régulièrement des promos des codes
promos vous achetez un produit on vous
offre la livraison on vous incite à
acheter le suivant enfin euh et puis il
y a la seconde main aussi qu'on voit
apparaître et qui vraiment bouscule
aussi les les les modes de d'achat
puisque là c'est à la fois pour des
questions de prix hein parce que
l'inflation explique aussi euh la baisse
aussi des achats mais aussi il y a un
petit mouvement écologique de se dire
bah c'est mieux de recycler plutôt que
d'acheter et de toujours consommer alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait le gouvernement est
inactif alors le gouvernement est les
commerçants demandent depuis plusieurs
années notamment les petits commerces de
revoir de de refonder le système le
gouvernement est pas inactif Olivia
Grégoire l'ancienne ministre du Commerce
a proposé de réfléchir sur le sujet
puisqu'elle a lancé dans le cadre du
Conseil national du commerce mais ça ne
vous aura pas échappé on n toujours pas
de ministres aujourd'hui spécialisés en
tout cas spécifiqu sur ce secteur donc
on attend demain mais en attendant et
bien écoutez c'est au point mort et
c'est vrai que les soldes sont passés de
mode h joli chute on enchaîne rapidement
avec Cécilia dont on est très heureux de
retrouver le le sourire solaire et les
bouclettes hein sororité bouclettes bien
s alors vous avez regardé de près
l'étude de l'Ifop publié ce matin qui
scrute l'activ l'activité sexuelle des
des Français c'est plus du tout ce que
c'était céiliia alors c'est c'est
vraiment c'est le sex est en berne
l'étude évoque un recul sans précédent
de l'activité sexuelle on a l'impression
qu'on parle de l'industrie une sexe
récession carrément et c'est donc la
crise la crise du désir sexuel chez les
Français de tous âges femmes homme et
notamment chez les jeunes on a les
jeunes on a moins le cœur à badiner
cette année un/art des Français qui
initié sexuellement comme on dit n'ont
pas eu de rapport sexuel et 28 % des
jeunes de 18 à 24 an éorme chez les
jeunes alors que c'était 5 % en 2006
alors pourquoi parce que est-ce que
c'est simplement que on le disait pas
avant rien n'a changé ou vraiment les
pratiques il possible qu'il y ait quand
même maintenant une une on se sens sur
moins d'autant que la question du
consentement dans le couple notamment
qui était pas très évoqué on faisait un
peu l'amour parce qu'on se sentait
obligé de le faire mais aujourd'hui en
fait on revendique le fait de ne faire
l'amour que quand on veut donc ça a
aussi contribué à faire drastiquement
chuter le nombre de fois où on fait
l'amour par mois en moyenne 6,6 par mois
mais plutôt une fois par semaine et en
plus il y a de plus en plus de coupes
qui sont ensemble et qui sont abstinents
c'estàd la question de l'abstinence
probatisé sobriété sexuelle par l'Ifop
en fait s'impose comme une nouvelle
façon de vivre son couple aussi est-ce
que les plateformes ont une petite
responsabilité alors les séries
notamment alors bien sûr la concurrence
des écrans trois personnes sur 10 qui
disent préférer regarder sa série plutôt
que de se livrer à une petite partie
fine euh et c'est aussi une autre façon
de vivre sa sexualité c'està-dire que
c'est on passe plus de temps par exemple
sur des plateformes pour chercher à
rencontrer des gens qu'on ne rencontre
jamais ouais donc il y a une forme
d'excitation d'autoexcitation il y a
aussi beaucoup de pornos beaucoup de
alors c'est aussi trois personnes sur 10
préfèrent les plaisirs solitaires donc
finalement il y a une sorte de d'égot
tripe sexuel qui se dessine il y a d'un
côté la sobriété de l'autre l'égot tripe
sexuel une forme de crainte de l'autre
aussi on a du mal à s'approcher de de
son corps et le le couple et la
sexualité qui avait été au cœur du
couple selon la sociologue Eva house ben
on a quitté un peu ce moment le sexe est
maintenant partout glorifié les
plateformes la sexualisation même
l'injonction à être performant
sexuellement notamment pour les femmes
mie et vailous elles n'y ont pas trouvé
leur compte finalement dans cette C
déréglement ce marché du sexe
déréglementé ne leur a pas apporté ce
qu'elles attendaient et en rendant ce
sexe libre et partout il a perdu alors
que c'était la pulsion vitale du monde
avec S ses interdits autour du sexe il a
perdu quelque part sa force pour devenir
une activité comme les autres un peu
comme un cours de Pilate oh non quelle
tristesse oh non PAL Pilate merci
beaucoup Cécilia gabizon plan plan cul
vous avez vu la Une de Libé ou oui il
faut s'en désoler ou c'est intéressant à
observer ouais ça ça
m'évoque une chose ce ce sujet là c'est
euh on est constamment enfin beaucoup de
gens sont pris par les
médias pas les médias télévisés mais par
les écrans par TikTok par Internet par
et cetera et cetera pour que le désir
puisse se développer parce que c'est pas
l'amourme au départ c'est le désir c'est
s il faut qu'il y ait de la latance il
faut qu'il y ait du vide il faut qu'il y
ait du besoin qui s'exprime et là dans
un univers saturé c'est plus difficile
de trouver la place pour le c'est sûr
allez on va se calmer un peu côté écran
pour faire remonter le désir merci les
filles merci Patrick auertell la
confiance nouvel horizon social c'est
àire aux éditions du champ social pardon
pour le retard fin de cette émission
soirée documentaire Jean-Pierre gracien
à
[Musique]
demain